so welcome um I will quickly introduce
myself I'm David I'm a PhD at sits lab
and um I might have a little bit
different background than most of you
because I'm originally biologist and
after my masters here at eth I worked in
um in industry in biotechnology as like
protein
engineering and after that I did a
second master's degree uh more in the
field of data science and uh now after
this I'm doing my PhD at SIDS lab uh
working on like graph-based engineering
of proteins and small
molecules and um the focus of this
lecture will be um mainly on AI models
for engineering of proteins and small
molecules and
uh um so for example to develop new
drugs or to develop new enzymes that
catalyze some specific reactions and
this is an extremely Dynamic field that
has experienced a couple of
breakthroughs in the recent years and I
will just try to give an overview over
the state of the research in the field
and the AI models that are used to like
help reach the goals of protein and
small molecule
engineering so
so in the first part I will quickly give
a short introduction on like proteins
and small molecules uh just that we are
like to explain the basics that we are
all on the same page and
then um I will start talking about um
text based text based AI models for
protein engineering and small molecule
engineering um and then I would like to
speak also about structure based AI
models for protein
engineering um but to do this I would
like to First explain um the AI models
that are um now used to predict um the
structure of proteins so you probably
all have heard about Alpha fold and
maybe also esm and yes after this I will
explain like the most common approaches
for structure-based AI um for protein
engineering and Engineering of small
molecules ules and then in the last part
um I'll try to give an overview over the
field of like generative AI for like the
noo U protein design but this will
probably probably be on
Friday so and if you have any questions
just uh raise your hand or write into
the
chat so um first of all the introduction
to proteins and small molecules so small
molecules are organic compounds that are
um small of a low molecular weight and
usually have less than 100
atoms so like organisms produce such
small molecules for example as
metabolites or signaling molecules for
example um this cortisol here um is a
stress hormone and U drives our
metabolism and um these small molecules
they can normally easily diffuse across
cell membranes and they can interact
with proteins and influence their
function and because of this it makes
sense that most drugs are small
molecules because they can uh go into
the cells and interact with proteins and
change some disease pathway for
example
and the structure of these small
molecules um because they are so small
can like usually allows for easy
synthesis in in the chemical
lab so and now proteins are larger
chainlike molecules made of a fixed set
of building
blocks so they are chains and these
chains they fold into a defined um 3D
structure known as the native
confirmation of the protein so it's hard
to see here but this is a is a chain but
it's like folding in 3D space um and
then these chains usually fold into some
kind of globular structure so as you can
see here if with this approximated
surface of this specific protein
here and this structure defines also the
function of the protein and these um can
be many things like proteins can be
enzymes so proteins that catalyze
specific chemical reactions or they can
be structural component signaling
molecules
Transporters um but like in general they
are extremely important they are like
the building blocks of our cells they
play like a key role in almost every
process um necessary for life
so um as I said these proteins they are
built of a fixed set of building blocks
um and there are these building blocks
are amino acids and there are 20
standard amino acids you can see them
here
and all these amino acids have kind of a
backbone so it's an amino group and a
carboxy group and you can always see
this here um this triangle of NC and
C is shared by all amino acids right so
these are like the links of the chain so
if you create a chain of amino acids
that fold into a protein um these
triangles here that every amino acid has
are like linked together to form this
chain and what differentiates the
different amino acids are the side
chains so you can see while this
triangle here is identical for all amino
acids um the difference um is what is
attached here at this um middle atom
here at the C what is called the C Alpha
atom and this attachment this side chain
is different for all amino acids and
also defines like the the chemical
properties of these amino
acids and another thing that uh
highlights like how important proteins
are is of course the fact that our DNA
um dictates the sequence of proteins
like the sequence of amino acids in
protein sorry so each triplet of DNA
nucleotides uh encodes for a specific
amino acid so our DNA is kind of red and
transcribed into RNA and this RNA is
then translated into um a chain of amino
acids and then once this chain of amino
acid is synthesized then it um folds
into a more ordered three-dimensional
structure which then defines the
biological function of the
protein so how this fold looks like is
um entirely defined by the sequence of
the amino acids and their side chains so
this folding is kind of a spontaneous
process of energy minimization that is
just Guided by um interactions between
the amino acids and between their side
chains for example like hydrophobic
interactions hydrogen bonds or
thunderballs
forces and then to describe a protein um
you can like think of these three level
of structure basically so you have the
primary structure which is just the
sequence of the amino
acids in the chain and then there
secondary structure which is um which
are like regularly repeating local
structures stabilized by hydrogen bonds
so for example um alpha heles or beta
sheets so this here would be an example
for an alpha helis and this would be a
beta sheet
and then tertiary structure relates to
like the SP spatial relationships of
these secondary structures to each other
so primary structure is just um which
amino acid comes after like after which
then this defines the secondary
structures like it forms into an alpha
helix or at some point into into a beta
sheet and then um the third level is uh
how these secondary structure um
organizations how they fold into like a
protein and how they relate to each
other in three-dimensional space and
this then gives the protein its final
shape and you will very often see um the
proteins in this cartoon depiction and
this is just used to visualize um the
secondary structures like the Helix and
the and the beta sheets and it gives a
nice like overview over the structure
but it only shows like the location of
the backbone of the amino acid so of
these three triangle atoms that each
amino acid has so the side chains are
not visible in this so if you would like
show the side chains as well then the
protein would have a different shape
like this here on the right side but
this cartoon just chose the location of
the backbone
basically so now I will quickly talk
about like how like engineering of
proteins and small MO ules and what what
the goals are of this
field so as I told you most drugs are
small molecules and they can bind to um
to proteins and affect biological
processes and the chemical structure and
the composition of these small molecules
um Define their function and their
binding
preferences so small molecule drugs are
usually engineered to interact with some
specific desire
Target and to bind to it to inhibit it
and modulate some disease pathway so um
the small molecule might for example
inhibit an enzyme or block a
receptor like you can see here and this
molecule Here Is Asprin binds to this
enzyme cyc oxygenase which would
otherwise like U form prostaglandins and
lead to inflammation and fever so in ing
of small molecules like happens through
altering like the size and the
composition of these organic compounds
to get some desired properties and
binding
preferences and then in engineering of
proteins uh it's all about changing the
sequence of the amino acids in the chain
to achieve a specific function of the
resulting
protein so for example in the field of
biocatalysis so in the field of uh
the research of
enzymes
um you could for example change an amino
acid sequence of an enzyme to accept a
new substrate for example here you want
this substrate to be um catalyzed or
this to be processed by this enzyme you
might change some of these amino acids
here so that this substrate can like
enter the active site or this uh pocket
in in the protein
structure and if if you think about like
Therapeutics a very um common example
would be that you change the sequence of
an antibody so that it can for example
bind to um SARS COV 2 Spike
protein and there are kind of um two
like a couple of strategies to do
protein engineering so there is like
rational design which is just you use
very detailed knowledge that you have
about your protein or your your system
to make desired changes so again in this
picture you might think for example that
um in order for this substrate here to
bind into the enzyme I might need some
hydrophobic amino acid here and then you
might make this
change um but semi-rational design would
be kind of you want this substrate to
bind so you think that this amino acid
is important and then you just replace
it by like all possible amino acids so
you make kind of combinatorial library
of protein variants where they which are
identical except for like one two or
three locations where you just try out
all
um all possible amino
acids and maybe you've heard of directed
Evolution which is also commonly used so
in this process you start with um A
protein that already has kind of a a
desired function and you would like to
improve it so
you introduce random mutations and from
the pool of generated variants you try
them you test them for their function
and uh you pick out the one that
performs best and restart the whole
process so it's kind of accelerated
Evolution and uh this process also got
got a Nobel Prize a couple of years ago
and but all of these uh like rational
design and direct Evolution they are
really time consuming and expensive and
are usually only suited to like optimize
existing proteins like make small
changes um to make a protein more
performant the main challenge about
these engineering uh tasks is like the
incredible size of the search space for
optimizing like proteins and amino acid
sequences so if you consider um that
there are 20 naturally occurring amino
acids and Each of which can occupy um
each position in a protein or in an
amino acid chain of length 100 then this
protein already has 20 to the power of
100 possible sequences and proteins are
usually um amino acid chains longer than
100 amino acids or a couple of hundred
up to a few thousand so yeah you can see
what I mean and that's where like AI
comes in and AI can like help to better
navigate this this search space and like
filter it down
and that's
um now where I will start talking about
text based AI models and I call this
text based AI models because um the
inputs to these models are text
representations of proteins and small
molecules so I will give a very quick
introduction to this so for proteins the
representation in text is really
straightforward because we have the acid
sequence and this is like a text
representation of the
protein and for machine learning um
amino acid sequences like this one you
can see here um are then encoded into
some numerical representation for
example with one hot encoding or other
kind of tokenization which just
uh each amino is treated as a separate
token and uh like words in text
processing
and for for small molecules it's a bit
more complicated so what is very often
used are in a Smiles code this is like a
linear notation representing the
molecular structure using some
characters so atoms are kind of
represented by their chemical symbols
single bonds are are omitted but double
bonds are equal signs and branches are
described with parenthesis and rings are
like denoted by by
uh by numbers like indicate their
connection points so you can see then
you can translate a small molecule like
this into like a
linear text
representation and for machine learning
these Smiles codes are also like
tokenized and mapped to to a fixed
vocabulary and you might have noticed
it's already like with tokenization and
text representations it sounds like
natural language processing and these U
methods have really had like a big
impact on this field um because there is
this analogy between like the building
blocks of language and those of proteins
and small molecules so in proteins like
in natural language um protein sequences
have their own kind of grammar and they
also contain these long range
dependencies so you can for example
think of amino acids as words and um
sequences of of amino acids as sentences
and proteins as for example a text
paragraph and for small molecules it's
uh similar they also are linear
sequences that consist of a fixed
vocabulary and there are also rules and
patterns of how they um how they are
written basically so both protein
sequences and smiles codes are
compatible with uh language model
architectures designed to handle such
linear sequences and that's why the the
methods of NLP are very often applied to
proteins and small
molecules and at this point I would like
to give you like a first oh there's a
question yes
yes so in in case of proteins the the
like the library of tokens that you need
is really it's just the 20 possible
amino acids right um but with smiles
it's a little bit more
complicated um you um but also there I
think they use a fixed vocabulary of
tokens um which is not that large and
then they just map these um Smiles like
each each recognized ible um group in in
the smiles to a
token
yes um I think it works it works fine
but I would need to look into into this
more more closely um
all right um so I would like to give you
a first example of a model that has
actually been generated by some chemists
here at eth and it's a Transformer model
trained to predict um
the temperature dependent limiting
activity coefficients of molecules um
it's not very important uh right now to
to know what this is it's just a
property that um small molecules have
that describes their behavior in a
solution
with a given solvent
solvent um and the input to this to
these models are um um Smiles of the
solute and the smiles code of the
solvent and the output is basically just
the predicted activity coefficient of of
the
solute so the smiles codes of the the
solvent and the solute are tokenized
into an input embedding and the
temperature information is added to this
input
Matrix and then this Transformer block
um like transforms these uh this input
embedding and uh feeds like the new uh
representation into into a regression
head that outputs a single value
representing um this uh limiting
activity coefficient
prediction and this model has been
trained on um experimental data so for
some molecules you just know this this
limiting activity coefficient so it has
been trained in a supervised Manner and
they have shown that they can quite well
generalized to other molecules um that
the model has never seen so this just as
a first example how these Smiles can be
used uh for a small molecule uh
molecular property
prediction
and now about protein you might have
heard about esm it's also quite famous
it's the model that has been trained by
by
meta and it's basically a
self-supervised learning model with the
masked language model objective on
protein
sequences so it was trained on 250
million uh protein sequences so a lot
and
um it works in a way that each input
sequence for example of this protein
here is corrupted by replacing a small
fraction of the amino acids um by a
mosque and then this um Mosk sequence is
encoded in a numerical representation
and this esm Transformer like
um generates a new representation of
these uh of this input sequence that
allows it to make a prediction which
amino aets have been masked in the
sequence and if the prediction is
correct so it Compares its prediction to
what has actually been masked and if
it's um not correct the prediction then
the model is improved and that's how
this model is
trained
and it turns out that if this model is
like consistently consistently
performing well on this task of finding
a couple of amino acids that have been
masked from the sequence then it needs
to know a lot about protein sequences
and protein structures also you can
imagine that this is a really simple
task but it's not easy at all so if you
for example want to fill a gap in a
protein you need to know a lot about
protein to make a good guess basically
so you also need to know about the
structure of the protein for example
because um some amino acids might
actually fit in in there and some might
not right so it turns out that in this
hidden state representation that the
protein generates uh the the esm model
generates sorry um there's a lot of int
intrinsic biological property
information and also information about
the protein structure and this just
encoded in this hidden state
representation in this embedding and
that's extremely interesting also
um to use this representations for
Downstream
applications and the authors they showed
this um also with this um orious uh
proteins so they showed that um if they
take some data set of orist genes and
proteins so these are um like related
proteins that um come from like the same
ancestral Gene basically so orist
proteins tend to have like the same
function and you can see the untrained
Transformer um takes these orist genes
um each like group of genes is colored
in one color and then the untrained
Transformer generates a representation
like this if you you take the
representation and um do some
dimensionality reduction with T for
example um you can see that the trained
Transformer is able to group ores and
proteins and cluster them
so it learns something about the
function of these proteins from these
250 million sequence that this is
trained
on so this shows that these latent space
representation that this model generates
are uh very useful for transfer learning
um so you can for example fine tune this
language model on a specific Downstream
task so you can use supervised learning
with a potentially quite small dat data
set that is labeled to fine tune this
model for a particular application which
might be like protein function
prediction prediction of mutational
effects U prediction of protein
stability or even the prediction of 3D
structure and the potential of these
self-supervised Transformer
embeddings um are currently like
starting to be exploited by more and
more uh researchers and models
so now I've already mentioned the
protein structure so I would like to um
transition to the next topic of protein
structure
prediction
so first before I start talking about
Alpha fold and and again esm I would
like to just quickly um say a few things
about protein structure and why it is
important so protein structure simply
said just refers to the 3D coordinates
of all the atoms in the protein in its
folded
state so and this knowing this is very
useful and important because it gives us
like more understanding of a protein
because the structure as I said earlier
defines the function of the
protein and so knowing the structure
helps us to find like the biological
role of a
protein and for drug Discovery for
example um knowing the protein structure
might help us to identify um some active
sides or some pockets in the protein um
that we might for example Target with a
small molecule drug for example if you
have the structure of this protein um
and this is a a bad protein involved in
some disease you might see that there is
some some Groove here and that this is a
good like Target site to Target with a
small molecule drug for
example however um for many years
researchers have always relied on very
time consuming methods to generate
protein structures like um x-ray
crystallography or um NMR to find these
structures for a given sequence but um
recently published models have like deep
learning models have made huge progress
in predicting uh structures um without
these experimental
procedures so quickly about the TOs of
folding a protein and predicting its
fold from sequence this is an extremely
difficult and challenging task because
um these amino acids have a lot of
degrees of freedom that can rotate
around their backbone bonds and side
chain bonds so the number of possible
structures for even a very small protein
is astronomical and um folding is also
driven by various different um
interactions
um which happen between the side chains
of the amino acids and they are really
difficult to model like hydrogen bonds
hydrophobic interactions and valls
forces and there are also long range
dependencies so the folding is
influenced by interactions between amino
acids that might be really far apart in
the sequence of the protein but then
come close together in the 3D fold so if
you
use a model to process sequences it
needs to be a model that can handle such
long range
dependencies and finally the training
data is relatively uh scarce uh even
though we have been characterizing
protein structures with these
experimental methods for for decades um
the number of um solved protein
structures is still relatively small
from a deep learning
perspective so so and for this task
because it's so important there's also
this critical assessment of protein
structure prediction um competition that
takes place every couple of years and
invites like researchers and uh um
machine learning experts to um to give a
try on predicting folding of proteins
from from sequences and this uh
competition was like the 14th holding of
this competition Was Won by Alpha Fall 2
and by quite a large margin and the
predictions of alpha fold showed a root
mean Square deviation of the C Alpha
atoms so the tips of these backbone
triangles that each amino acid has of
only
0.96
enroms so this is the root mean Square
deviation of these C Alpha atoms and to
compare like the width of a carbon atom
is 1.4 enstrom so it is quite precise
the prediction of alpha
fold and you can see here also like an
experimental structure in green um like
aligned with an alpha fold prediction
just as an example um how precise Alpha
fold can be and this is really kind of a
breakthrough in the field of structural
bioinformatics that's why I will now
dive a little bit deeper into like
architecture of alpha fold um but still
I can't like explain everything because
it's quite a complicated um model so I
will explain it on quite a high level um
but important to know is that the input
to the model is basically the input
sequence the protein sequence that you
want to fold and then what the model
does it it searches a genetic database
for uh similar sequences um possibly in
in other organisms and makes an
alignment and that's what what is called
a multiple sequence alignments so it
generates this and then it also looks in
a structure database for similar
proteins that um for which already a
structure exists and using um these
templates um it generates a first guess
kind of of the pair wise distances
between all amino acids in the protein
so it kind of generates a first
prediction of the structure based on
these templates and some statistical
statistical analysis of like known
protein
structures and then from this multiple
sequence alignment and this pairwise
distance Matrix um the model generates
this MSA representation and the pair
representation so the MSA
representation um is just the multiple
sequence alignments translated into this
um representation containing like a lot
of sequence conversation information and
um also about sequence entropy and the
pair representation is uh as I said
based on the analysis of known protein
structures uh called templates and it's
kind of an initial prediction of the
pairwise amino acid
distances and then these two
representations they are passed to the
AO for forer which is um the core of the
alpha fold
architecture and this um Transformer
model updates these two representations
through attention mechanisms and
convolutional like operators and
generates like a new
representations with like updated
representations and um then these are
passed to to the structure module Which
con converts these updated
representations into spatial coordinates
so it predicts the distances between all
the residue Pairs and the angles of
bonds in the protein and from this
constructs a 3D model of the
protein
and it also applies this interesting
concept of
recycling um that you see more and more
often um nowadays so it's kind of an
iterative refinement process where the
output of the structure module is like
fed back to the AO former multiple
times so if the model has made a first
prediction it's not outputting this
prediction yet but it's um giving it
back and adds it to the pair and MSA
representations and makes another pass
of the model so this helps refine the
predictions by allowing the network to
reconsider its earlier outputs
basically and this benefits like the
model benefits of the additional
contextual information that it gets from
subsequent layers so they do this
recycling three times before they output
the final um structure and the 3D
model okay and alfold training is also
quite complex there are several uh
structural objectives
so um where deviations from the true
structure is like penalized with
different loss
terms and in addition to this there's
also like a a a birth objective what
that's how the authors call it because
they randomly masked a part mask a part
of the multiple sequence alignment and
the network is then required to like
reconstruct the Mosk regions and this is
also like an additional um training
objective and then there's also an
interesting principle applied the the
training with self
distillation um so they have a certain
data set of protein structures that have
been resolved with these um experimental
methods over Decades of hard work and
they train their model on this data set
of known structures using conventional
supervised learning um but then
once the model has achieved a certain
level they use sequences of another
350,000 proteins of which we don't know
the structure and make a prediction
using that trained model and then once
they have made this prediction they
merge the two data sets they take the
experimentally derived structures and
their predictions of this already
trained model and retrain the model from
scratch on this merged data set
and they you can repeat this several
times and this um apparently makes
effective use of like unlabeled
sequences of sequences of which we don't
know the structure and apparently this
really improves the accuracy of the
model which I find very
interesting
good
so just check the time
maybe is it all right if we take like a
10minute break now and continue
after all right is everybody here can we
continue
nice so before the break we talked about
Alpha fold to predict protein structures
and I would like to um remind you of
this model here that I showed earlier
the um self-supervised
um model trained on 250 million
sequences with this masked language
model objective and this model um has
been um Extended or first
the the authors they have shown that in
these hidden State representations that
are generated for this model there's
also information about the structure of
the protein so so the model cannot
observe the protein structure directly
because it only gets sequences but the
structure of the protein is kind of like
a hidden variable that influences the
patterns in the sequence so the model
can still learn about the structure of a
protein only from the
sequences and they showed this um by
using a data set of known like of
proteins with known structures and then
added a label to each amino acid of
these proteins like whether they are
part of a helix or a strand or a coil so
the type of secondary structure they are
in so you can see this here like the and
the strands are in green the heles are
in
red and then they derive this
Transformer hidden representation for
all the proteins in their data set and
then they just fit a very simple
logistic regression classifier to
predict a secondary structure like to
classify each um for each amino acid in
the protein whether it is part of a
helix or of a strand and they show that
with this very simple classifier and
using the the hidden state
representation um as
input they can achieve quite High
classification accuracy um regarding
these secondary structure elements and
this shows that um this self-supervised
training only on sequences also
like encodes information about the
structure of the protein in the
representations of the
Transformer and then um there has been
like a second version of this model
released um so
esm2 and they have extended the the
model with a folding
hat and
that that just extracts Atomic
coordinates from the hidden State
representations of the esm model so they
take this esm model that has been
pre-trained and on all these 250 million
sequences with the mask language model
objective and they um fine tune it and
add this U folding Transformer block
here they also apply this recycling
strategy from alpha fold and then they
train this they fine-tune the model on U
300,000 experimentally determined pdb
like protein structures from the protein
data bank and they achieve um prediction
accuracy similar to Alpha
fold
so this is kind of remarkable because
this model removes the most costly
aspects of alpha fold so it doesn't need
to access any databases to find look for
templates and similar sequences so it
doesn't have to do this multiple
sequence alignment and this makes the
model about 60 times faster um to to
predict protein structures compared to
Alpha fold and it's like completely
Standalone so it doesn't need external
databases so it just take sequences and
outputs um a
structure and if we compare the um
performance and we split this comparison
into like backbone atoms and side chain
atoms
so you remember the backbones are the
three atoms The Links of the chain right
um so both models perform quite well to
um predict the structure position of
these backbone atoms but Alpha fold is
often a bit better and regarding the
side chain atoms this is a bit more
difficult so the performance of both
models drops because these positions of
these side chains are usually harder to
predict uh because they are more
flexible and Alpha fold still generally
performs better in positioning these
side chains so if you have an
application where high accuracy of
backbone atoms and side chains is really
crucial then I would recommend you use
Alpha fold but um esm and esm fold
provides like a really valuable tool if
uh quick predictions are needed uh
across for example a vast number of
proteins and just in general the
obtaining of protein structures is a lot
easier thanks to such uh
models but you also um have to be
careful because there are still only
like near experimental accuracy and also
regarding protein Dynamics there's some
things you have to like consider that if
a protein is very flexible and um has
like parts that can move can constantly
um do this because proteins are Dynamic
then from this whole range of dynamic
movement of protein Alpha fold and esm
will just give you some average
confirmation basically so it's a bit
difficult you might for
example um predict the structure of an
enzyme of which you know it capitalizes
a certain
um small molecule
or substrate and then you predict the
structure of this enzyme and you find
out that in this structure the small
molecule doesn't fit into the active
site anymore this is because the protein
in in reality like can move a bit and
can like open its active site a bit and
then it can be that your Alpha fold or
esm structure gives you a confirmational
state that doesn't allow for this
substrate to enter the active site so
you have to make some
some uh yeah you have to think about
this that this can be a
problem so now that we have um we know
how to predict protein structures with
deep learning uh I would like to talk
about AI models that use this structural
information as
input so I will first um talk about 3D
convolutional neural networks and then
about graph-based models
but uh before I can do this uh I will
give a short not so short introduction
to to graphs and graph neural networks
so that we all have like the basics to
understand the models that will follow
then yes
um so if you take a protein that has
like a few hundred amino acids then it
might um take like 15 minutes would be
normal for Alpha fault for example but
um I think with esm it's less than a
minute so or for small proteins might be
10 seconds something like
this all right so
first um I will repeat some um concept
about the structure of proteins so the
structure of proteins as I said
determines the the function of a protein
and these proteins they fold into these
complex shapes that like allow them to
interact with other molecules and a a
protein sequence alone provides like no
information about the actual arrangement
of the atoms in 3D space right so models
that incorporate not only the sequence
of a protein um should be superior at
tasks that require an understanding of
the physical U placement of residues for
example um tasks of interaction
prediction or enzyme activity prediction
so I guess uh you agree with me that
to make a prediction whether this
substrate here can be processed by this
enzyme um the information of the
physical placement of these residues um
will be quite or should be really
beneficial for for a successful
prediction but there are also like
challenges Associated to using
structural data so um structural data is
much um less available so it's limited
availability and sequence-based methods
are usually uh more um simple and more
computationally
efficient so about 3D cnns I will
explain just the the general procedures
and how these can be used to for example
process
proteins and so if you have a protein
structure like this to
convert the atomic coordinates into a
format suitable for a 3D CNN the space
around the protein is divided into grit
of so-called
voxels and then you can use different
types of atomic properties um to Define
multiple channels in the input data for
example the types of the atoms here in
this example they have a carbon Channel
and a nitrogen Channel and an Oxygen
Channel and then they use like
convolution and pooling to extract the
relevant information
um from these threedimensional
grids and in the end if they have
reduced it to a single Vector they use a
fully connected layer to derive like a
global
prediction and such 3D CNN have been
shown to perform well in tasks such as
protein stability prediction for
example and this example uh is also a
model that um some people here at eth
have developed um it's a
threedimensional CNN for the prediction
of protein lant Affinity
prediction and Len like refers to a
small molecule that binds to a protein
so as you can see here um this small
molecule binds for example to this
protein structure and the Affinity
refers to the strength of this
interaction so if this binding is strong
or weak and they want to pred ICT um
given an input structure like this so a
protein with a bound small molecule if
this interaction will be of high
strength
basically so what they do is they Center
a grid um around the geometric Center of
this liant and the position of each atom
is then like um mapped to one of the
voxels and they also use additional
chemical properties of the atoms and the
structures to Define additional channels
for example here they have a channel for
aromatic carbon atoms one for like
hydrogen bond donors and for something
else and then they use also a
convolutional neural network that
reduces this 3D grid um to a single PKD
value which represents an affinity
prediction and such 3D CNN were the
first structure-based
models to outperform sequence based
Affinity
prediction okay but these 3D CNN also
have some drawbacks so the model sizes
are usually much larger than uh compared
to 2 dcnns the parameters of the models
they grow kind of cubically with the
resolution of the grid and the size of
the grid and sparcity is also an issue
because if you for example model such a
molecular interactions like a portion of
the the voxels in your grd might just
represent empty or homogeneous regions
that don't really contribute any
meaningful information and the
inefficiency arises because these um
boxels are still processed by the
model and then rotational invariance is
also a problem so to achieve invariant
predictions regardless of the spatial
orientation of the 3D object in the
input data you have to present these
objects in multiple orientation which
makes training of the model also a lot
more computationally um
costly
so 3D CNN usually require large uh
training data sets to perform well and
to avoid overfitting and training and
inference require sign significant
memory and processing power so the
application to large data sets of
structural data is limited for example
if you do some molecular Dynamic
simulation and you want to process like
the frames you generate during this
simulation um it would be better if you
had something that is a bit more
efficient and a potential alternative to
these 3D cnns are a graphs like graph
modeling and graph neural networks and
so I'll give you now um a short
introduction to this um before I start
talking about graph-based AI
models so graphs describe a set of
objects uh that are then called nodes
and the connections between these
objects that are called edges and
information in such a graph can be
stored in each node of the graph and
also in each edge of the graph and you
can for example also have some Global
context Vector some data that is
associated with the
graph and this is a really powerful
representation of data especially for
non- ukian and unordered data for
example you can think of a social
network with friendships or citation
networks or also the atoms in a
molecule and graph neural networks are
just neural networks that have been
developed to process such graph
structures so if we look at this
potentially a social um network with
some interactions we can build a graph
representing like people as nodes and
their relationships as edges for example
and then if we have this we can um save
the connectivity of this graph so which
individuals or nodes are like
interacting with other individ uals we
can save this connectivity um in an
adjacency Matrix which is a square
Matrix with the dimension number of
notes in the graph times number of noes
and the elements of the Matrix indicate
whether pairs of nodes are connected or
not so you have either a one or a zero
in this Matrix um and this tells you
that for example this person is
connected to this
person so a second second example would
be um this caffeine molecule here that
you could represent represent as a graph
and then it's this is a very convenient
and natural abstraction to describe
molecules um where atoms are translated
to nodes and the bonds between atoms are
translated to edges and for this
molecule a graph would then look like
this and the adjacency Matrix would look
like this
then to pass such graphs to a neural
network we have
to we need to um bring this type of
information that is associated with a
graph into a matrix format so the note
features The Edge features the
connectivity and also the global context
so what you usually do is you assign um
each node an index and then you store
the features of these nodes uh so the
feature of node e in row e of the note
feature
Matrix so
um then for the connectivity of the
graphs um you have this adjacency Matrix
as I explained before but
um we usually expect the number of
connections to be much lower than the
number of entries in this Matrix so
these M adjacency matrices are usually
very sparse as especially for large
graphs and uh that's why usually this
other representation this Edge index
which is kind of an adjacency list is
often used and it's like a more memory
efficient way to represent the connect
the connections in the graph without
using like memory for uh showing like
saving the onconnected parts of the
graph so you basically have a list of
notes that are connected so node two is
connected to node one node 3 to node one
node 3 to node two and so on and this is
a much more sparse representation of the
connectivity right and then if you have
this Edge index you can save the edge
features in the edge feature Matrix in
the same order
as in the edge index
basically and then the global context
Vector you also just have it in a matrix
format and then you can pass these
information to to a graph neural
network but um first like what kind of
tasks do we want to solve with graph
neural
networks
and something really common or is is
like a graph level task so you have an
entire graph and you want to predict a
single property for this whole graph so
for example taking this graph of a
molecule you might want to find out is
this molecule an
antibiotic and then there's node level
toss s so you predict some property for
each no in a graph so this is a super
famous example this this toy data set um
of this karate club um where the two
instructors they have um an argument and
they split they have to split the club
and you have this graph of the social
interactions between the members and the
task is to predict like which member
will uh stay loyal to which of the in
structors so it's a node level task
because you want to predict something
for each node in the
graph and there are also Edge level
tasks which predict um a property or the
presence of edges in a graph so a good
example would be like the Friendship
suggestions on
Facebook so starting with graph neural
networks um a GNN or graph neural
network is kind of an optimizable
transformation on all attributes of the
graph so the notes are transformed The
Edge features are transformed and the
global context Vector can be transformed
but it preserves the graph
connectivity so it's this graph in graph
out principle that the model accept a
graph as input with information loaded
in the in the nodes edges and the global
context vector and then progressively
transforms these embeddings without
changing the connectivity of the
graph
and if you for example want to do binary
prediction on the notes like for this
karate data set then to get a prediction
for each node in the graph you could for
example apply a linear classifier um to
the transformed node embeddings and then
derive a prediction for each node
the same could also be done for edges if
you want to classify some relationships
for example between the members and uh
the edge features and the global context
information they can also be included if
you for example want to make a
prediction on the
notes so to opdate and transform these
features that are saved in the notes um
in the mates and in the global context
Vector um gnns usually apply this
message passing neural network framework
so that neighboring nodes or edes
exchange information between them and
influence each other's updated
embeddings and this makes the the
Learned embeddings aware of the graph
connectivity and aware of the
neighborhood like of of a given node in
the
graph and this message passing Works in
three steps so if you look from the
perspective of this node here you want
to update transform its features then um
you gather all the neighboring node
embeddings or messages like those from
these two notes it is connected to and
you aggregate these messages using an
aggregation function here in this figure
it's just adding them up um and you
usually include uh the node features of
the node that is of the node in question
basically so and then once you have
these aggregated messages you pass them
through um an update function usually a
learned neural network to like U
generate the new node embeddings for
this node and you do the same thing for
each node in the graph collecting
messages from other connected nodes
aggregating the messages and passing
them through like a small neur Network
to generate new um node embeddings the
same can be done also for edges you can
also convolve um do message passing from
edge to
edge and this message passing process
has uh some similarity to convolution on
on images on 2D images so both are
operations that Aggregate and process
information um of an element's neighbors
to update the element's value
basically so in graphs the elements are
neighboring notes and in images the
elements are the neighboring pixels so
in in graphs the number of neighboring
elements so the number of neighboring
noes can be um variable but in an image
this is not the case so the Neighbors in
an image is just the adjacent pixels
right so this is one difference but you
could basically say that image
convolution can be thought of a graph
convolution on a graph with an ordered
structure where each node represents a
pixel and is connected to its adjacent
pixels so because of this similarity
this message passing process on graphs
is also called a graph
convolution and as in 2D images that are
processed with cnns we can also stack
graph convolutional layers then if we
for example have three layers um a Noe
after the three layers um will have
information about nodes that are up to
three steps away from it
basically because in each layer messages
are sent like along all edges and then
if you do this three times information
will flow along three edges
basically and there are several types of
graph convolutional layers that are
commonly used and each has like a
different aggregating function to
aggregate information from neighboring
nodes so I have shown here just two uh
basic ones so this gcn conf flayer it
um updates the noes uh the node features
of node e for the next layer l+ one um
using this formula here so for each
neighbor of node e which includes also
itself um you take the features of this
neighbor the note features you multiply
them with a learnable weight Matrix and
then you normalize and with the degrees
of the two um nodes and you sum this
term up for each neighbor of a given
node I and pass this through an
activation function to get the new node
embeddings for this node I and this um
attention graph attention Network layer
Works similarly but it also sums over
the neighbors takes the features of the
neighbors multiplies them with a
learnable weight
Matrix and with an attention score so
you compute an attention score which um
refers to like um the tension score
between this node I and the node J so
and these tension scores are computed
based on the features of the two nodes
and the edge between them so this is a
convolutional layer with some attention
scoring so from each noes perspective
you basically assign a certain weight to
it
neighbors so and these weights are taken
into account in this aggregation
function
good so
um I will continue now with the graph
based AI model give you one or two
examples um and hope that this
introduction was was enough to um help
you understand these
models um so this is a a very nice paper
from 2020 where they trained the graph
neural network to predict whether
molecules have an antibiotic effect or
not so it's kind of a graph level binary
classification task so you generate a
graph
representation of the molecules in your
data
set and then they added also a chemical
data to the nodes and the edges so for
each node which represents an atom they
added Atomic proper properties like what
type of atom it is what what if it's
charged and this kind of information and
for each Edge they added information
about the chemical bond it represents so
like if it's part of a ring or like if
it's a single or a double
bond and then they use these graph
representations that are like featued
with this chemical information um to
train a graph neural network and the
training set in this case was and 200
560 um drug molecules of like diverse
structure and function and 120 them um
of them were um labeled with known
growth inhibition of eoli so 120 of them
are known
antibiotics and then they do very simple
graph convolution on on these
molecules and apply a global pooling so
after the node features and Edge
features are transformed
they take the features of all um notes
and edges and pull them into a single
representation and feed this into a
neural network that outputs like the
predicted probability of growth
inhibition of
eoli
and then once they have drained this
model they applied it um to a large or
to a larger library of molecular um
structures to the D repurposing hop
which with 6,000 molecules so they did
inference on this uh library of drug
molecules to do some classification if
some of them might be
antibiotics and it turns out that among
the 99 molecules for which the model
predicted highest probability actually
51 of them showed growth inhibition
against eoli and just to compare among
the 63 molecules that reive the lowest
probability predicted by the model um
only two of them displayed growth
inhibition so this is quite a remarkable
result I think
yes
um yeah the question is how they avoid
overfitting given that the training data
is like the training data set is really
small and
yeah I'm I'm not exactly sure like about
regularization techniques that they have
used in their model architecture but I
know that the architecture of this model
this graph neural network is also like
extremely simple so it will also have
very few parameters but I don't know by
hard how many how many it is but that
this certainly helps I think but yes
given that the data set of for training
is really small I think this is quite a
remarkable result and it also
led to the discovery of holine which uh
is like a new antibiotic that displays
bacter cdal effects like against a wide
range of different
bacteria and you can see like here what
they published in their um in their
paper that you you have a certain um
concentration of
bacteria um and if you incubate them
with u concentrations of this Hol holine
molecule you will see that
um the concentration of bacteria um
declines so they die and then here they
also took the same bacteria and
pre-treated them with ayine quite an old
antibiotic for which um some resisting
um bacteria strains exist already and
you see
that some of the bacteria they persist
after being treated with pyin and they
just show that they can even kill these
persistors right so um if they apply
this holine so it's just a functional
antibiotic that has been discovered um
in a very simple manner basically and
interesting is also that this new
antibiotic has kind of a low structural
similarity to other known
antibiotics which um suggests that the
model was kind of capable to generalize
it didn't just predict molecules that
have a similar structure to the
antibiotic molecule molecules it has
been trained on but it kind of
generalized and accessed somehow new
antibiotic chemistry which I think is
quite uh interesting that this has
worked
so
then this study has modeled small
molecules as graphs but you can
theoretically extend this also to
proteins right because proteins are um
just large molecules with a fixed
vocabulary of building blocks so you can
also Model A whole protein as a graph
right and this here is like a a graph
modeling on atom level but um this study
I would like to show uses a kind of
different approach so more Co grained
approach um it's a graph convolutional
neural network for the prediction of
protein functions so it takes um protein
structures and then it models them as a
point cloud of amino acids so it reduces
each amino acid to its C Alpha atom
basically and
uh then connects these points
representing the C Alpha atoms of all um
the amino acids it connects them if
there are less than 10 onms apart part
and then you get kind of this
U
interconnected graph that um shows like
the structure of the protein and it's
kind of a contact map which is the input
um to this convolutional neural
network so um they also
featuri um these amino acid nodes with u
embeddings derived from a protein
language model so they can for example
use embeddings um generated by the esm
model and put these embeddings into the
note
features that represent like the notes
that represent amino
acids so and then they have like three
layers of graph convolution uh with some
skip connections as you can see here and
a global ad pooling so they again pull
the representations the transformed
representations of all the notes in the
graph and then
generate like with this a single
representation um Vector basically and
pass this to a fully connected neural
network to derive like um probabilities
of like class memberships for each
protein so like a prediction what to
what class the protein belongs and with
this also like what function the protein
might have and this uh simple um gcn um
outperforms um um many machine learning
tools for protein function
classification and it suggests that the
main reason why this model Works uh so
well is that this graph modeling that is
applied of the protein structures so
there are basically
um the convolution sends messages
between residuales in this graph
structure between residuales that are
distant in sequence of the protein but
end up being really close to each other
um in the 3D structure of the protein so
these residues are then connected
because they are close to each other in
the 3D structures so the model has kind
of a better awareness of the protein uh
structure right and that's hypothesized
that this is the main reason that this
model has performed better yes
um like a feature in the sense of uh for
example like a graph level feature so
how for example um a function of of a
molecule um evolves over time that
doesn't make sense now um
I'm not I'm not sure actually so would
be interesting to look into
yeah
so I already reach U the summary of this
part so graph neural networks offer many
advantages for modeling and processing
3D objects such as
molecules and they can handle data that
is defined in um irregular domains
without in them onto a regular grid and
so graph representations are also
invariant to translations and rotations
if you remember that in the 3dcnn you
have to present the object in different
orientations but in graph neural
networks this is not the case and um
it's also a much sparer representation
of 3D objects um than these voxal grits
that we talked about and there are many
possibilities for data integration can
save data in the nodes in the edges in a
global context vector and um incorporate
this information in in the update
mechanisms that graph neural networks
have so these graph convolutional neural
networks uh perform well in tasks where
like an understanding of the structure
of the inter and the interconnectivity
of the data is is important and they are
usually they usually perform quite well
with relatively few
parameters so to summarize the whole
lecture um the text based AI models so
proteins and small molecules can be
represented in in text and handled
efficiently with methods of natural
language
processing and language models trained
on these text representations can
generate very informative latent space
represent ations and are even able to
predict the structure of
proteins and uh structure-based a AI
models um usually perform better in many
tasks where information on the spatial
placement of the elements in the data is
crucial and graphs are ideally suited to
to model and process this kind of
nonukan and unordered data such as
molecules and social
networks and as an overall conclusion
like the engineering of proteins and
small molecules is very very challenging
because the search space is just
incredibly large and these kind of AI
models that I showed you um they they
can and will probably much more in the
future help to navigate these search
spaces and um accelerate development
processes for example for new drugs or
new functional
enzymes so
so I suggest that we um stop here and on
Friday I will uh talk about very recent
new models about um that like generative
AI models for like the inovo um design
of proteins so without having an actual
protein that you change but you just
generate new structures from scratch for
example with diffusion uh
processes yeah will be interesting so
thanks for your attention and hopefully
see you on on Friday